yet still learning t-shirt no button ups
because that's what happens when you use
a moving crew and a company that's not
you to move your [ __ ] so yesterday my
friend and I pulled a double feature
we're like alright we'll watch Jack the
giant slayer then immediately after that
last exorcism - last exorcism - were
rated pg-13 horror movie yep I was like
people are gonna talk on this it's gonna
be miserable we're gonna power through
it and my god did this crew of people
just not shut up it was really
infuriating I'm already mad because I
don't have all my clothes and all my do
you realize how empty my place is right
now I was looking for any excuse to get
out of there so I was like I don't want
to watch it Last Exorcism - I don't want
to watch it with these idiots and then
this new trailer for the Evil Dead came
on a trailer that many of you have asked
that I do a video on I hadn't seen it
ever so he's gonna pass it by it I
apologize for that cuz after I watched
that I was like holy [ __ ] and if I saw
that trailer I was like okay here's the
thing I turned to my friend and I was
like alright I'm clearly watching Last
Exorcism - to do a video that's why I'm
here I'm not here for the enjoyment but
I'm telling you right now I can do a
video on that we can leave now call it
good don't have to put up with these
[ __ ] or the movie he was like cool
so we left and I have no regrets done
let's talk about this trailer so the new
Evil Dead movie coming out is a remake
of the old Evil Dead movie which is
pretty much the template for cabin in
the woods creepy trapdoor and evil book
that you read out of and then bad [ __ ]
starts happening is it's very familiar
but that's the point of cabin in the
woods I gotta admit some of the imagery
in this trailer that is some [ __ ]
I don't know if there's a point and
purpose to it we've all seen the Texas
Chainsaw Massacre stuff I've seen them
reboot things like this before but this
trailer has a tone where you're like if
the movie lives up to that trailer it
will be something you'll walk out of
going I'm gonna remember that I hope
that's the case anyway it involves
everything creepy about creepy movies
some chicks freaked out of her mind
she's like talking with that whisper
he's gonna be like you don't look okay
is everything fine either of course they
got to do the whole like multi-voice
thing which is it's pretty commonplace
now so when sub chicks all like
I'm like okay venom you're gonna have to
do a little more than that you're gonna
have to be like Kristen Stewart and
Emperor Palpatine lovechild if you're
gonna creep me out
[Music]
okay yeah no I'm creeped out that kid
was creepy dude you see that [ __ ] I'm
not saying evil Dead's going to be new
it's not gonna be new just based on the
fact that it's a remake of an old movie
but it's like the game makers of this
movie we're like we understand where
this movie's coming from we understand
the fans are hardcore so we're gonna do
all of that justice I like that I like
seeing that why moments like this I
wouldn't even know what to do of a
little ghost weird creepy zombie Darth
Maul eyed girl the saying that to me
this movie's gonna be nothing but brutal
image rage graphic violence every sudden
that's the reason I was watching it that
was like I feel uneasy watching this
trailer which is probably the best
compliment I can give the movie I so
evil Dan have you seen the original are
you looking forward to this remake are
you like not remakes No in either case
whatever you're going for comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]